all he's so fashionable when I'm about
to head to the airport which is where
I'm going Jenna and I are heading to the
Indy 500 this weekend I'm kind of really
excited because I've never really ever
watched the Indy 500 I honestly have no
idea what to expect but when they
brought up this idea of hey would you
like to go and check it out and cover it
my role is basically never say no to
something that sounds really really fun
so I'm kind of excited to learn about
this whole world so I'm looking for your
guys's help help me know what to do what
to look for what I should be going to
check out I don't know all I know is
I've got GoPros I've got cameras
whatever happens happens and that is us
this is this is how we this is how we do
just pointed with a beverage
okay I'm gonna do the coffee tea and
water alacrity
you turn your Chinese right
oh great
you've arrived we're here up where they
walk sprained my ankle on genna's
Channel I did that I was hop I was up
here hippin and hoppin dancing and stuff
and real turnt up that I jumped out I
was like I'm in pain I'm gonna open up
my bag yeah yeah sunscreen well it's got
to be quite important we're legit get a
view on the pit crew look at Jenna we on
the pit crew do you know how to change a
tire no so clearly we made it to
Indianapolis and we're now heading to
our first events we were heading to stay
in shape where we're gonna be hanging
out with Graham Rahal and hopefully a
bunch of you guys because I tweeted and
told you guys that I'm gonna be there
Jenna's gonna be there and grandma's
gonna be there let's let's do it shall
we
event waiting for Graham actually fly
Jay and Jenna fans out there so guys
good
this is going to be really fun okay and
this is the first item I have this is so
cool yeah oh yeah
Oh
a little lump is like you know fast
I'll walk it in
is your butt gonna fit in the car okay
okay
it's looks like you're on a roller
coaster okay I'm gonna get my leg
something I want to show them the inside
of this car real quick let me just hold
on one second sorry
this is what we're dealing with like I
had to get my little legs inside it also
says it's just a mock-up but look at
this that has to be terrifying like
racing it I I'm just I'm so scared